[Applause]
wait so how many of us are you hey
everybody there's a whole bunch of
spider-man that just dropped so a bunch
of you been requesting a video for the
spider-verse stuff as well as homecoming
too because it sounds like we might be
getting black cat in the homecoming
sequel even though it's not gonna be
called homecoming - they'll have some
different title for you but they haven't
revealed that yet maybe because it's
kind of spoilery for what's going on -
ring infinity war but if you are finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos and
there is a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway but if you guys didn't
know Liev Schreiber was playing the
villain of the spider-verse movie that's
the animated one that we're gonna be
watching later this December there is a
lot of spider-man related stuff
happening in the next 18 months or so so
we have a homecoming sequel we also have
the venom movie and we have the animated
spider-verse movie so everybody's seen
the spider verse trailer it very clearly
looks like they're doing a version of
Miles Morales origin story in the
ultimate spider-man comics but a lot of
you correctly guess why would they title
it into the spider verse as in
spider-man multiverse without actually
doing some of that stuff from the comics
like they even put it into the trailer
how many of us are there but you get the
idea they're teasing the idea of an
alternate universe where there are just
many different people who are part of
the spider family but here when we get
to the villain part of this it'll make
sense on the second level they're also
teasing more of a multiverse storyline
which gets into spider verse from the
comics but I think what's going on is is
they're like dipping their toe in the
multi-verse pool before they cannonball
in been chasing that pointy-eared freaks
and alternate words
gets weirder I ran into six other
versions of myself some even knew my
secret identity so even though they're
doing spider-verse from the comics
they're not gonna be throwing all that
stuff at you because if you read that
storyline it actually wasn't the
greatest like they'd just spam different
spider-man all over it in the payoff
wasn't quite as great there were a lot
of conspiracy theories about why Marvel
did a story like that because it was at
a time when they still didn't have
access to the spider-man character in
this all these conspiracy theories about
how Marvel tries to dilute brands that
it doesn't have access to in the films
like you may have heard the crackpot
theories about how Marvel took all their
Fantastic Four characters out of Marvel
Comics just because they couldn't get
access to them in the movies but
obviously that's all a moot point now
because Disney is buying Fox they have
them back but for a while it seemed like
Marvel Comics was doing that with their
Spiderman brand they were just diluting
it across so many different titles it
was Wallis Andrew Garfield stuff was
going on but the main villain of that
storyline was more lun they originally
announced that Liev Schreiber was going
to be the villain of the spider-verse
movie but they didn't say who he was
playing people have supposedly been
saying that he's been confirmed as
Merlin I've had trouble verifying that
but it would make more sense that they
would call the movie into the
spider-verse if they were using a
spider-verse villain from the comics so
that doesn't mean that they're not doing
Norman Osborn or ultimate Green Goblin
or any of the other ultimate versions of
the characters because I think first and
foremost they're just teasing the idea
of Miles Morales ultimate spider-man
from the comics before they go crazy
with multiverse spider-man and a bunch
of different versions of the character
and I think even when they do that
they'll still whittle it down to a
couple of different versions of
spider-man but if they're gonna do the
Miles Morales origin stories they do
actually have to do a version of Peter
Parker to explain why he put the mask on
but getting back to the more Lund of it
all if you're not familiar with who his
character is he's the supernatural being
that was created for the express purpose
of hunting down all the people who
possessed what they would call spider
totems so that's guys into some really
crazy mythology about the spider-man
character like he gets his powers from a
spider bite the spider had been
genetically modified but then later in
the comics they turned it into more of a
black panther situation where like black
panther
gets a lot of his power from the panther
totem also through the heart-shaped herb
so it's a combination of science and
mythology they did the same thing with
all the different versions of Spider Man
for a little while and the movies
obviously haven't addressed this which
is why I think that this is gonna be an
animated universe thing only but more
Lund was this supernatural being that
was created to hunt down all of them
across the multiverse and take back the
power from their totems so he became
this main antagonist for the spider-man
multiverse so it makes sense that he
would be the villain for a spider-verse
movie but it really would be like
jumping over Darth Vader to get to the
Emperor so they are going there very
fast I don't know how they're gonna use
him during the movie or what they're
gonna tease in terms of other versions
of Spider Man from other worlds but I
think part of the idea is that they're
hoping to turn him into sort of like an
animated version of Thanos where they
can spin out a franchise from these
animated spider-man films and they can
do whatever they want and it doesn't
have to crossover with the live-action
films it doesn't have to get super
confusing in that way so they can get as
crazy as they want because it's
animation and there aren't any
limitations like you would have with
live-action filmmaking in terms of
budget or big action set pieces or even
doing really crazy stories with a
billion different versions of the
character like imagine how weird it
would be if five different versions of
Spider Man popped up during infinity war
maybe they'll have some joke about that
too because we are getting into the
multiverse of the live-action movies
[Music]
just let me know in the comments what do
you think about the idea of moreland
being the big bad of the Spider Man
multiverse in these animated movies and
getting into black cat stuff so there's
a lot of people that have been reporting
that they're actually looking for
someone that sounds exactly like the
black cat to show up during the
homecoming sequel this is me just
reading from the press releases the
pitch says Peter Parker will cross paths
with a mysterious European young lady
that will likely lead him into danger
which is basically like they're doing
big classic characters black cat is one
of those types of people where she's
kind of bad but she's kind of good
basically the Catwoman of spider-man
comics hey crime spree there's hoping
you'd swing this way
I think like a thief a boat full of
overdressed fat cats is a can't-miss
proposition wait mmm now waters is
wearing the Stuyvesant Tiger still no
idea about how old the character would
be if it be an older version of black
cat like she'd be in her 20s or 30s
because Peter is still only gonna be
about 17 when homecoming two picks up
because the timeline is gonna get a
little weird between the next couple of
Avengers films in the homecoming sequel
but it gets a little bit easier to track
when you just remember what Kevin Feige
said about the spider-man movies that
are doing this is sophomore year is the
next one
junior years the next one senior year is
there a is there a summer break between
each of those I don't know what but it
was sort of how do we how do we do a a
journey for Peter you know not
dissimilar for what the students of
Hogwarts would go through each of their
years which was one of the early ideas
we had for the movies they're gonna have
him do the Harry Potter thing where they
just see him in a different school year
each year so he was a sophomore during
homecoming that means the next
spider-man movie he'll be a junior than
the third movie he'll be a senior he'll
graduate and who knows what'll happen
after that the Sony sharing arrangement
with Marvel for the character only
extends through the homecoming sequel
after that they'll have to sign a new
deal and just decide what they want to
do with the character for the next 10
years but I mean come on spoiler alert
of course they're gonna reassign that
sharing arrangement Sony has made so
much more money because of what Marvel
has done with the character there's no
way they're gonna go back on that they
would lose access to all those a list
Avengers that they would put in those
spider-man movies Marvel would just
circle the wagons they'd have the x-men
characters and everybody would just
forget about Sony as a company they
would just die on the vine so no way
they're gonna cut spider-man out of that
they're probably gonna hype him up even
more as a phase 4 character like the new
Iron Man esque type character of Bay's
fourth we actually almost got to see a
version of blackhat during the Andrew
Garfield movies but they never quite got
to that point during amazing spider-man
2 Felicity Jones from rogue 1 played a
version of Felicia Hardy
right mm-hmm
what's your name Felicia Felicia from
now on everybody at this table works for
Felicia because Felicia works for me
didn't really do anything with that
character if you remember they actually
had a version of Mary Jane played by
shailene woodley that they cut out of
that film too there were just so many
characters they stuffed into that but we
did technically have a version of black
cat in the spider-man movies big
question though who do you want them to
do for black cat in the spider-man
Marvel movies in how old do you want the
character to be do you want her to be
about Peters age or do you want her to
be a little bit older really big news is
is that we got the Super Bowl coming
next week there probably be some Marvel
stuff dropping between infinity war and
Black Panther announce the giveaway
winner when I post my next Marvel video
which should be in the next couple of
days but leave all your requests in the
comments below click here for brand new
Black Panther and Avengers and click
here for a brand new flash thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you